[музика]
надішліть такі по мережі це не стануть
росіяни сиділи
а наші почне коли ж вечір зі старшим
було дуже страшно
[музика]
наші знижки щодо його людей дітей
просто розуміє він натягується все
пачок плутай пальчик них то я пропаду з
гіркін тут від руки в скиту туди і просто
димом живі гірше просто ніхто їх не
вірні
[музика]
щоб розуміли 27 лютого у нас
світла і не тужити андрей води ми живемо
the phone's кома димос живемо холод нас
не встиг надіти ні і ми стаємо в холоді
можуть готуємо слухати приносимо поки що воно
гаряче ми намагаємося як а потім і
так починається привід
[музика]
я живу кого на 100 але не кличу 34 за
кузова і на оборону та стріляв і на
ховалася по льохах
де ти сам кутку столітті час і ринку
[музика]
я помру зараз ми не можемо хоч і
розповідати поки ви майже
[музика]
отриманого тему з вами була вони всі
плакали боялися я
можу я ніколи мислення протягом 20 хвилин
вони поставили вийшов вони повели антени
ось ці які
деяких було
городище могли щось там будь він же
можеш сприймати вона були
фонового
сильно плакав не тільки двічі ось так
просто
не прямо а коли 10x солдати я петрович
два автомати -2 наводять долота зараз
так мені сподобався стріли вали людей
просто в машинах ось тут тобто на стукіт
навалити а тут стояли машини голі
розстріляні просто в машину
і я не знаю ну ти ж не в 32 ти ж дня
три пішні ці машини стелла ми таких
знаходимо
місяць
на місяць прожив у підвалі не виходячи світу
на вулиці один раз ви запускаєте аптеку в
пологовому будинку років наша 8-а
штаб-квартира відбувається крок те що вони
робили в мене
йде безглуздо видно крилатському вони вони там
курили цей учень якщо
вони перерили так що місця не знаю
піднімається
вночі кипіш залітають двоє, але не п'яні
були коротші за це ставлять відразу тут
калау очей поставили на коліна гармату
мене взагалі вивели за будинок туди
ну слава бу
1 бахнув вгору її колонок стрільнуть
але
ми
вже почали було падати тут і бомби
раді футбол та авіація була
[музика]
ми користувалися тим, що у нас було -
знайти ялинки скачав один раз на день потім
вже стали трохи по два рази
розтягувати це харчування
вже коли ми бачили нашу поліцію яка
проїхала, а після них через день приїхали
наші guys маска але якось нас але ми до
досі то розповісти вам треба давити
чи ні але ми матчу прокидаємося та
прислухаємося їсти і тиша авто ми
тоді можемо дозволити собі далі
час треба присвятити себе як волонтери
намагаються допомагає ось
сьогодні взяли і навіть потяг який
такий сірники туалетний папір зубний
паста чи дякую велику та й
хлібів sabaton attero грунт далі
вони бачили але на світ завдяки
чудовим
став ось ці сухарики це порятунок
знати це злітати було і п'яточка прийом
путах лісу ось
вона ж у тебе щастя у нас його у
нас забрав і минув і я не знаю що будемо
на самій
[музика]